نشرت منظمه هجوم رويتس تقريرا بشان القصف
الروسي على محطه قطارات كراماتورسك شرق
اوكرانيا حيث قتل عشرات المدنيين في
الثامن من ابريل نيسان من العام الماضي
ووصف تقرير منظمه الذي اعاد تسلسل الاحداث
المحيطه بالهجوم الروسي وصدر يوم الثلاثاء
وصف استهداف المحطه بانه انتهاك وجريمه
حرب ادت الى مقتل 58 مدنيا على الاقل
واصابه مئه اخرين بعد استهدافهم بصاروخ
باليسي مزود براس حربي من الذخائر
العنقوديه حيث انفجر صاروخ فوق المحطه
مطلقا عشرات القنابل الصغيره التي انفجرت
على الارض مخلفه عشرات القتلى والمصابين
ممن كانوا يحاولون الفرار من الحرب بمن
فيهم الاطفال وكبار السن وطلب التقرير
بالتحقيق مع القاده الروس المسؤولين عن
الامر بالهجوم ومحاسبتهم يذكر روسيا نفت
من جانبها استهداف المحطه او استخدام هذا
النوع من الصواريخ